في اقل من سبعه اشهر على دخول القوات
الروسيه مقاطعه خرصون في اوكرانيا وبعد
قصف المدمر بالصواريخ وانتشار المكثف
للجلود فيها لم يكد يستقر غبار المعركه
التي تشهدها المدينه حتى جاء النبا الجيش
الروسي عن الانسحاب من خرسون واحده من
اربعه اقاليم اوكرانيه اعلن الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمي بوتين ضمها وفرض فيها الاحكام
العرفيه لاحقا امر الجيش الروسي باتخاد
مواقع دفاعيه على الضفه المقابله من نهر
النيترو وقال الجنرال سيرجيو كين قائد
القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا انه لم يعد من
الممكن ايصال الامدادات الى مدينه خرسون
واضاف انه اقترح اقامه خطوط دفاعيه على
ضفه اليسرى للنهار
الحالي اقترح مواقع دفاعيه على طول الضفه
اليسرى ابني مبروك اعرف ان هذا قرار صعب
للغايه في الوقت نفسه سنحافظ على ارواح
جنودنا والفعاليه القتاليه بشكل عام وهو
امر لا جدوى منه في منطقه محدوده على
الضفه اليمنى ويعني ذلك ان القوات الروسيه
ستنسحب بشكل كامل منظفه اليمنى لنهر دي
برو وتمثل الخطوه تطور اللافتا لانها
الاولى من نوعها في خيرسون منذ سيطره قوه
الروسيه على المخاطعه في مارس اثار الماضي
وتقود القوات الجيش الاخراني هجوم مضاد
للسعاده مدينه حرصا ذات الموقع
الاستراتيجي على الضفه اليسرى لنهر ديني
برو بالقرب من مصب البحر الاسود الطريق
نحو شبه جزيره القرم التي تحتلها روسيا
منذ عام 2014 وهي مهمه ليست سهله لان
المدينه محصنه بشكل جيد منذ سيطره الروسيه
عليها في بدايه الحرب على اوكرانيا